ghost in the shell i yes i'm about to
ramble because of a motion poster they
ever even put a new trail out but I'm
going to anyway because they're really
they're really sticking with this um
they didn't save your life they stole it
tagline and it's wrong you know that
kind of line and I didn't like it when I
heard it in the trailer and I'm really
not liking the fact that they keep
coming back to it now and marketing
material because it points to a drastic
oversimplification of the sorts of
questions that the major should be
asking because a major absolutely should
be questioning and she should be
questioning her reality she should be
questioning her identity she should be
questioning her place in the world but
not because of a government conspiracy
to hide her past steal her future
whatever she's not Jason Bourne she's
supposed to be asking huge personal
philosophical questions not I wish I
could remember my past as the cheap
cyberpunk or espionage twist is like oh
but there's something in your past that
they're not telling you know she knows
her past you know who she was what she
doesn't know is who she is who she is
becoming and she's questioning who she
is now and for the record I am in the
process of reading the original manga
which I'm about how thoroughly into a
now it's an odd experience if you've
never read the thing because reading it
has firmed up a suspicion that I've had
for a long time which is that pretty
much every subsequent version of ghost
in the shell is taking its cues not from
the original manga but from the 1996
animated film particularly when it comes
to character of major Motor Co Kusanagi
because in that original manga there's a
lot of stuff that's just
gone in terms of tone and
characterization a lot of lightness a
lot of goofiness lot of kind of pure
I'll name-calling between characters the
major is frankly not nearly as serious
as she is in every single art
incarnation she's ever had so nobody can
tell me that they went back to the
source material on this if they went
back to the source material than the
major will be sticking her tongue out at
our Maki I don't think that's going to
happen and doing this whole they met
they stole your past whatever thing is
not putting a new spin on the thing like
that is an oversimplification and this
this work and particularly this the
original anime cell which at this point
is very clear to me this is the template
everyone's working from this is the
first adaptation that most mainstream
audiences are going to get don't don't
water it down don't simplify give them
the thing that people who have already
seen the original know is great and now
I know that things are coming for me
given that I've complained that the
thing seems to be taking so many direct
visual cues but as the thing I don't I
don't want it to literally copy and
paste that original animated film but at
the same time if i take my old baggage
out of the equation i think just in
terms of someone's cold experience of
going in and seeing this who doesn't
know the animated film it doesn't have
my baggage associated with that i would
rather they see a live-action film that
is true to what that animated films in
terms of the ideas and the scope and the
heaviness of it rather than it gets over
simplified and dumb down I mean my true
preference would be if they could do
something like what the tent alone
complex series did which was to take the
feel of that film but do as actually
some different story beats and sort of
bring a little bit of its own flavor but
still very very clearly sort of having a
similar visual language without directly
lifting stuff that would be my true
preference but if my actual choice is
either recreate the animated thing but
keep the big ideas or don't retreat the
direct animation don't just
being pasted it but oversimplify I would
rather have that but I'm actually afraid
we're not going to get either of those
we're going to get it something that
copy and paste a lot of the visuals and
the action beats but at the same time is
going to simplify the story to something
less petty less thought-provoking less
interesting it was original so there you
go this is my mood I've been in lately a
motion poster will sent me off on a rant
I I need a spa day or something so
there's my latest ran blood goes from
the shell what are your thoughts on the
current thing you still looking forward
to the movie why why not whatever you're
feeling drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give those
who the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned